Hello Freak bitches.
Hey,
this is a quote from Ray Kurzweil,
which is things aren't getting worse.
Our information's getting better,
right?
And so with Hillary Clinton,
who is a career politician,
right?
And we've all known since we were young,
most people,
I think when they think about politicians,
they don't think those
are some honest people.
Those politicians,
they usually are telling the truth.
I think most of his think politicians,
they lie,
they warp things,
they fabricate things,
they use a form of deception to gain
control of various power structures.
That's what the animal does.
So that's not new information when you
find out that Hillary Clinton and the
DNC,
and I don't know if they
completely connected those two,
but when you find out that they,
they,
they were not,
they didn't do what
they're supposed to do.
They helped Hillary Clinton become the
Democratic nominee and they actively
tried to fuck up Bernie Sanders.
Right?
That's creepy.
But it's not a new thing.
I know,
but it is creepy.
It's creepy.
And it's even more creepy that the
woman who was in charge resigns and then
immediately gets hired.
Great Shot.
Got It.
Great job.
Hillary Clinton's like,
fuck it,
I'm going to hire you
and it won't do anything.
She hires her.
She's so fucking unafraid of what's going
to happen that she hires the woman who
did such shitty thing,
she
had to resign booed off stage.
Hires her into her fucking
party cause she's like,
fuck you.
I'm getting elected.
Are Not stopping it.
Right.
But this is again tech.
It's gangster too though.
It's also a move in on her part where,
I mean she's looking at it like what
Trump is calling her crooked Hillary like
yeah,
it's a gangster move to
hire a woman like that.
Like right in front of you.
Yeah.
Wasserman Schultz top post
mission accomplished the DNC.
This is,
this is not a new,
this is not a new thing man.
This is what exactly,
well let's go over this because what
exactly did they do that's so awful about
Bernie Sanders?
What did they do?
They apparently came up with a way to
disseminate information to the press,
highlighting certain aspects of Bernie
Sanders that would be unappealing to the
voter
and they did this and this
has all been confirmed.
Can you,
can you,
uh,
Google that?
Find out what they actually said.
Let's find out what the,
actually summarize the Wiki if we think
they're being a bunch of whiny bitches,
but for sure they wanted him.
Look,
she's got way deeper arms in politics.
She's way more connected
than he is for sure.
There's,
and this is what we're seeing too,
that it's like a big part of being a
political candidate is how many favors do
you have?
How many people you are you connected to,
how,
how deep does your influence go?
Right.
And obviously her influence didn't just
sit within her are her own little group
of people that were working for
it had gotten to the DNC itself.
So she's,
she's deeply embedded
in this whole system,
whether it's because of friendships or
ideologies or people just wanted her,
she's the chosen one.
Whatever reason,
whatever deals were made or whoever,
who knows who knows what it is.
But when you find out that an organization
that's supposed to be the head,
it's supposed to be,
if we,
if everything was on the up and up,
it's supposed to be objective and looking
for what the people want as the best
party,
but now they're actually
actively steering it,
which is massively corrupt and kind of
scary is that these people are deciding
to steer an entire party,
which is 50% of a political
process because there's no,
look,
you've,
we've got libertarian party for the first
time people are taking Gary Johnson.
Seriously,
it's going to do that.
Um,
um,
a town hall debate on
Wednesday or town hall,
one of those town hall
things on Wednesday on CNN,
but for the most part it's Democrats
or Republicans in most people's eyes.
So would there essentially doing
is rigging half of that process?
Yup.
That's Carrie that we just,
we don't think anything's wrong with that,
but we put Martha Stewart in jail for
not telling exactly the truth about where
she bought and sold stocks or
whatever the fuck she lied about.
We do that
think something's wrong about it,
but we can't do anything about it.
We do think something's wrong,
but right now,
but okay,
so if like that institution is corrupt
and if the Republican institution is in
some ways corrupt,
I think it might be safe to say,
and I don't think too many people would
be outraged at the idea that there is a
institutionalized corruption in the
entire American political system and it's
very similar to the problem
that happens in bike racing.
If one motherfucker rigs their bike or
gets on fucking doping stuff that can't
be detected.
If you want to have a fair advantage,
you've got a rig your
bike and start doping to,
or the person who rigs
their bike will always win.
So if politics is a competition,
which it clearly is,
and if members of the competition are
using nefarious means to achieve their
goals,
which they clearly are,
then that would imply that if you
wanted to survive in that system,
you would also have to
use nefarious means dom,
dom.
Wow,
this is not new.
This is old,
old,
old shit.
What's new is technology.
What's new is now people like Julian
Assan change are shining a light on the
corruption in his whole ideas.
If I reveal this information,
it will force reform via the outrage
of the people who are supposed to be
represented by a person
who's breaking the law.
That's his idea.
We need reform.
And right now we're at the point where
it's very similar to when you're in a
family and this is one of the
worst things can fucking happen,
man.
In a family.
If there is somebody
who's molesting somebody,
it happens all the time where uh,
uh,
a father or a brother,
we'll start fucking molesting somebody,
right?
But in people in the family know it,
but they don't do anything about it.
Because to talk about what GRANDPA does
every couple of years means the complete
disintegration of the fucking family,
an apocalypse for the family.
And the same way is more of
these revelations become clear,
which we always knew.
But you could always float
into a happy place and be like,
Nah,
I'm just being a conspiracy dude.
I'm sure the stuff they're doing up on
Capitol Hill is all fair and square.
I,
you know,
you can just pretend to
believe it now it's like,
well now you're wrong.
Look,
hey,
here's the fucking proof and here's going
to be more proof and there's going to
be more proof and there's going to be
more proof until finally the American
people are going to have
to either just be like,
I'm just going to believe that fours
three and three is four because I have a
nice comfortable life and I don't
want to fucking deal with this shit,
man.
I'm just going to trust the
banks because the banks lie.
They like money at my job
and as long as I keep my job,
I'll keep my benefits.
Yeah,
and by the way,
ps,
man,
when you consider that,
it's like there's something
pragmatic about that.
As sad as it is theirs,
as,
as depressing.
It is.
But they're the real awful
problem is that this country,
I think is that they get metaphysical
machine that was built by some very
intelligent people who understood the
energy flow that comes through a society
and the elections were supposed to be
an outlet valve for the pressure that
builds up when people feel
that they're being repressed,
right.
And if you start fucking with that output
valve by putting up fake politicians
that don't truly represent the people and
hope that the people will believe that
they have elected these people,
if you put two shitty choices in front
of us and we're supposed to look at that
and be like,
okay,
everything's fine,
then you're,
you're missing the point,
which is that there is an energetic
system that needs to get released.
You know,
at some point the energy's got to go out.
If it doesn't go out,
you get revolution.
That's what the way the
energy goes out the wrong way.
The idea is let's fucking
the American revolution,
brutal,
bloody,
awful fucked these geniuses.
Many of them Freemasons got
together and they were like,
you know what?
Is there a way that we can program
history so that a society doesn't destroy
itself intermittently
with a fucking revolution?
Because if we could do that,
we'll build one of the most powerful
never ending societies on earth because we
figured out a way to outflow
the pressure that builds up.
So when you start fucking with a goddamn
political system and pretend that
everything's gonna be okay,
you are missing,
I think the the point which is
that people who are very smart,
maybe a lot smarter than
then the politicians we have
today recognize something,
built a thing and said,
let's just trust the fucking people.
Let's trust the people release
the steam and while ah,
everything runs according to plan.
Now the gears are a little
fucking gummed up man.
A little,
yeah,
a little how gummed up,
how gummed up the gears
are really crazy comes up.
This is the first time we're realizing
how much money people make by running for
president.
How much,
you know,
money costs to run for president.
But how much money top political figures
make and donations and in speeches have
you,
have you paid attention to how much they
make in speeches like Rudy Giuliani and
Hillary Clinton and
Bill Clinton may bribes?
Well,
this is what it is.
These corporations can fund various,
uh,
universities.
They can donate money to have all sorts
of different programs where they would
have someone speak and they can decide
who gets to speak and who doesn't get to
speak.
And they also have like
the Clinton Foundation,
people donate money into that.
They don't donate to sh fuck loads
of now it's all these things,
but hold on a second says all these
things with what they are essentially.
Or you're,
you're paying someone to speak for an
hour and you're going to give him $750,000
and you want me to pretend
that that's normal.
That's crazy.
And what does this person do?
They are a public servant.
Okay.
So there are public servant and
while they're publicly serving,
they're also making $750,000 to talk.
Yeah,
that seems a little crazy,
doesn't it?
Like,
why do they make so much money to do that
and who was paying them and what what,
what do you have to benefit by having
them come and read some nonsense,
bullshit,
boring speech.
A friend of mine went to see Rudy Giuliani
after post nine one one when he was
on his victory tour.
He was on like a lap of
the country doing these,
these speeches because everybody loved
him because he's saved the world.
During September 11th he was
the guy who stood strong,
everybody like,
wow,
Rudy Giuliani,
he's a good man.
So he wrote that and he started doing
these speeches and he'd come to colleges
and a friend of mine went to see him
and said it was dog shit that he just,
it was a boring ass like
reading with no passion.
It was a chick chain go in there and
say some nonsense about freedom and the
American way and terrorism or whatever
the fuck and first responders and just
there.
There wasn't anything real.
It was just,
it was a performance.
It was like he was doing a one man show
all across the country for exorbitant
sums of money.
God,
that'd be fucking great if he was
actually doing a one man show,
hundred and $53 million in bill and
Hillary Clinton speaking fees documented.
This is just,
Jamie just pulled this up.
That that is stunning.
That's a s dunning amount
of money and whatever,
15 years.
It's from 2001 to about now it's it still,
it's more than,
yeah,
that's mean.
Well,
it's perfect then because
that's $10 million a year.
This is more recent of which shit,
2100 25,000 that's our standard fee.
Oh my God.
She prefers a private jet and prefers
a Gulfstream four 50 or larger.
The memo outlines at Clinton
requires travel by private jet.
Yeah.
You know,
it'd be fucking cold out.
Is this like,
what if you are like a mad billionaire?
Could you just get Hillary Clinton to
come to your house and like just speak to
you for an hour and your living room?
This is fascinating.
Hold up,
but scroll back down there.
She may $21 million to and what?
She made 21 point $6 million in
speeches and just under two years.
That's amazing.
That's incredible.
That's so much money.
She's like a kind of like crazy animal
that you can like lure with money.
Like you can actually,
if you have enough money
you can learn again,
Hillary Clinton into your house.
Like you just have to lay it out.
She'll show up.
Like if I put carrots in my backyard,
I'll probably get a rabbit or two.
If you have enough money,
you can get politicians to come
and start feeding it your mansion.
When does it become,
when does it become bribe?
Okay,
so should she like say,
well,
you can never be,
it's weird,
right?
You couldn't be someone who is in public
office and go and also have like a,
a book reading tour where you read from
your novel about crime or something like
that.
You'd have to be like a no
fiction person who's we?
When you're talking,
you're talking about what you do for work.
That's part of what you're talking about.
Like,
nobody's gonna re ask Hillary Clinton
to come and speak about the history of
jazz in the United States.
Right.
She's not going to give speeches on that.
It's going to give speeches on politics.
Right,
right,
right.
So,
okay,
so why is that okay.
Why can you like have two jobs?
That means you're having a second job.
Like you're doing your job.
Like you're,
you're saying the things
that you say during your job,
but somebody else is paying you to,
why is it okay that,
why is it okay to do that?
Like,
that seems like that's like,
that seems like very problematic.
Right?
Why is it okay for your
husband to go talk?
Who was he talked to you that the
head of the whoever the prosecutor,
who was he to district his Bill Clinton
went and had this secret meeting with
what's his,
who was it?
What about what?
Well,
right.
Oh,
right,
right.
Uh,
Lindsey,
what the hell is her name?
I've had it.
I lost it.
Dammit.
The point is like you just
are openly like hiring,
hiring the,
the,
the woman who somehow warped the process
of getting a Democratic nominee there.
Yeah.
What's her name?
Loretta.
Loretta Lynch.
Yeah.
Doesn't that sound like a country singer?
Is that uh,
yeah.
That's fine.
We're gonna land first.
I was like,
oh,
that's isn't right.
Yeah.
Loretta Lynn,
right.
That's what it sounds like.
Loretta Lynch.
Yeah.
Now she met Bill Clinton meets with the
attorney general on an Arizona Tarmac
now list,
by the way,
flew in on his private
plane and said that he,
it was impromptu.
Who Love Fuck flat and
prompt to on a private.
Yeah.
Hey,
you know what?
who are we flying over right now?
He's one of us.
Wait,
are we flying over?
Loretta Lynch.
Oh,
come on,
stop down.
I'm going to get a piece of Apple Pie.
She's a good one.
We're going to sit on the
porch and drink lemonade.
Talk about our grandchildren on the porch,
on the tarmac.
Nothing I love more than a nice,
a nice picnic on the tarmac of an airport.
Well,
this is the other
saying that she lied about being dead
broke after leaving the White House.
Right.
Not only dead broke,
but in debt.
She said that apparently the system,
so not true.
Yeah.
And now and now it's like t tea.
To make matters worse,
it's like you have to it.
There's this weird idea that's like,
listen,
you might not like
Hillary fucking Clinton.
Can you go back to that real quick?
Yeah,
but they're like,
you better shut the fuck up about her
because do you want Trump to be president
daddy's?
What's going on?
Right?
Yeah.
So good.
It says here,
this is what,
this is where it's confusing.
It says,
when Hillary filed a financial disclosure
document after entering in the Senate
in 2001 she reported assets of less
than 1.8 million in liabilities are more
than 2 million.
Well,
where are they doing?
What were they doing with all
the money he's spending money on?
There's like,
who the fuck?
Okay,
who has like $2 million in
assets and in $2 million in debt?
Do you have $2 million in debt?
No.
Most people don't have $2 million in debt.
That's,
that's a crazy amount of money.
Like,
did you guys have a budget?
You're dead broke now.
You guys are crazy.
He party and you guys do a
blow and buying Ferrari's.
Just staying on a Amazon lady.
Who the fuck gets $2 million
in the hole like that?
Dan is like,
if you want it to have someone that
you wanted to balance the budget,
wouldn't you pick the person that
doesn't get 2 million in the hole?
I mean,
no man,
it tracks Trump's been
bankrupt a gang at times too,
right?
How's he been
bankrupt a few times?
Yep.
That's what they say.
He says he likes going bankrupt.
It's somehow part of some plan.
But now the question,
what about the shit about Saudi Arabia?
What is this?
You don't remember this?
I remember when it was like Saturday
night live was making jokes about them
stealing like uh,
like silverware and fine
China and stuff from it.
When they were like leaving
like on their last day,
what year was this?
Was like two and from 2000 like when
they were literally living in the bushes
were coming in.
Oh my God.
Taking all sorts of extra artwork
and all clocks and kinds of things.
And I don't know if it's true,
but it's,
it's,
I don't think the meme has gone away.
I don't know,
man.
Ha.
That's hilarious.
She's so gangster.
Pardon me?
Look,
I,
I kind of appreciate it in a way.
She's like our Putin.
Uh Huh.
Yeah.
Great.
Just what we need.
[inaudible] part of me
appreciates how gangster she is.
Okay.